WEARING DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
ALLEGING VOTER FRAUD DURING THE
2020 ELECTION.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THE TEA
PARTY?
THEY EMERGED FROM HIGH
DISSATISFACTION OR HIGH TAXES
AND INCREASED DEBT AND MORE.
KEVIN LOOKS BACK ON THE MOVEMENT
THAT ENDED UP MAKING
A DIFFERENCE.
>> ♪ ♪
.
>> [CHEERING].
>> THEY WERE PATRIOTIC AND
PRINCIPLED AND PARTISAN AND
POWERFUL.
THE TEA PARTY FORGED IN
FRUSTRATION AND FIGHTING MAD
ABOUT SKY HIGH TAXES AND
GOVERNMENT SPENDING RUN AMUCK.
IT’S AS IF THEY WERE CHANNELLING
BOTH HOWARD JARVIS AND HOWARD
BEAL.
A TAX ACTIVITY AND THE LATTER OF
NETWORK MOTIVE FAME WHICH GAVE
RISE TO A POLITICAL MOVEMENT
THAT COUNTED AMONG’S SUPPORTS
WHO’S WHO OF CONSERVATIVE
LAWMAKERS.
THEY TOOK ON THE GOP PARTY
ESTABLISHMENT SPEAR HEADING
OPPOSITION TO GOVERNMENT RUN
HEALTHCARE AND HELPED
REPUBLICANS TAKE BACK THE
CONGRESS IN 2010.
THEY LATER ORCHESTRATED
A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN AND FORCED
THE OUSTER OF THE HOUSE SPEAKER
JOHN.
MUCH HAS CHANGED.
THE CAUCUS IS GONE AND SO TOO
ARE THE REPUBLICANS UNDONE BY
BUDGET DEALS AND CONGRESS’S
DECISION TO SUSPEND THE DEBT
CEILING.
>> FISCAL CONSERVATIVES SHOULD
BE IN MOURNING.
>> THE FIGHT CONTINUES.
TRILLIONS IN SPENDING THANKS TO
THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC COULD MEAN
A RESURGENCE.
IT COULD PROVE ITS EPILOGUE
RATHER THAN A REBIRTH.
WITH 3 MILLION SUPPORTERS STILL
BACKING TEA PARTY GROUPS IN 2021
SUPPORTERS SAY THEIRS IS
A MOVEMENT WITH PLENTY OF POWER
TO YIELD WITH THE MID-TERMS